all right the big trade in the nba
unbelievable and you know lebron james
had to sign off on this because you're
not doing anything on that organization
without him giving the thumbs up or the
green light they needed to add somebody
this offseason clearly they're not
constructed to win a title
and they shock everybody by trading for
russell westbrook i i can't believe it i
think it was great they got rid of kyle
kuzma you know he was never going to
turn into anything with the lakers
but now you have an old guy who wants
the ball in his hands all the time
and he cannot shoot three-pointers and
the lakers are 28th in the league and
threes
he never shoots him he can't shoot and
he wants the ball all the time i
jury is out on this thing but i think
anybody that really follows the nba
their initial reaction is this was a
horrible trade for the lakers what do
you think really yeah bad trade
okay especially when they could have got
benny the the guy from sacramento benny
uh mike baby no buddy yeah
mike baby was also being discussed you
don't think they thought about all right
look
he's okay let's just start the facts
he's the most triple doubles of all time
the guy is a walking triple double the
guy's
a freak athlete lebron freak athlete
the brow pretty damn gangster guy i mean
you're gonna be hard-pressed to find a
bigger
better a better bigger three than those
guys maybe the guys in brooklyn we just
talked about kyrie if they can stay
healthy
but they're gonna be the favorites
certainly in the west it ain't gonna be
phoenix who knows if they're gonna if
they're gonna resign chris paul
and you know for a fact they're to
surround them with shooters they who did
they trade away kuzma
uh andres harrell kcp yeah yeah first
round
they're going to go get like the kyle
corvers of the world and you know maybe
bring
my boy jason capono out of retirement or
something or tim legler
whatever get them off yet but they're
gonna have some shooters out there well
if they can stay healthy that's gonna be
a bad team the problem is they don't
have any money i think they're left with
like under 10 million well that's why
you don't pay their
taxes right but you get the kyle korvers
of the world for you know the
the minimum bad minimum they have some
exceptions but that's why
we all react to these trades the trade
is kind of incomplete because it matters
who you fill in
the roster with with those shooters and
defense right look let me just
add one more thing i huge miami heat fan
i was in miami when
and i've been going to gainesville since
1988. i was there when we signed
you know when wade lebron bosh and the
big three
and everyone on them who they were
there no luxury tags where they gonna
spend
they went out people were dying to go
play with them they got shooters galore
they got you know players to take
minimums jason williams gary payton
richard lewis whoever it was came in
took the minimum because they won a
championship you're gonna see names
like j.r smith hasn't been in the league
in a year or so
veteran minimum yeah knockdown shooter
like you're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna get guys
that want to play that that's probably
rob palinka's strategy but here's the
difference
lebron was in his prime during those
years in miami and he's
a little bit past it he's got you know
one or two more years and i just don't
know if russell
westbrook is going to be the answer
they're going to be fun to watch it's
going to be they make it to the final
give a prediction do they make it to the
finals
i don't think so i mean unless anthony
davis does something drastically
different where he can stay healthy
because it's inexcusable what he does
and how
and how often they can count on him it
was just you know he needs to be on the
right lebron's going to stay healthy
obviously about thirty three now so i
last thing to think about
you talked about lebron getting older do
you think lebron wants to be driving to
the hole every single play no he's going
to be working on his three-point shot
and let westbrook do his thing because
westbrook look i know he said he's
getting a little bit older the guy
was ridiculous this past year he was
maybe he's 32.
he makes things happen he's 32 years old
he gets in the lane yeah you know he can
score
you know he's going for the triple
doubles they'll be fun to watch because
they might implode or they might
they might go all the way so what do you
think lebron three-point percentage next
year because you're right he could be
the guy at the y that's just
then draining uh that's that means shots
look lebron the beauty of lebron he's
such a ridiculous athlete inside outside
just depends what he works on i remember
when his mid-range was just like
not falling in miami in a shot and they
were backing off and they lost to
dallas in the finals he spent the whole
next year working on a shot
post moves he's going to work on
something this summer i think whether
you love lebron or hate lebron
you know that guy works his ass off he's
going to be working to on his shot for
sure this year
with russell breswick knowing that
that's the one part of his game that is
lacking is his three-point shot well
thank god he doesn't have a movie to
shoot this summer so he can work on
something so that's great
you